more than 30 years after liar's poker
was published it is still the book to
read if you really want to understand
what drives wall street michael lewis's
1989 bestseller told the story of his
experience as a bond salesman in the 80s
it was a time of excess and greed roller
coaster markets and fabulous wealth and
scandals all captured in newspaper
headlines at the time now lewis is
revisiting liars poker with a newly
recorded audio book in the companion
podcast called other people's money
lewis visited the old federal reserve
bank building in san francisco to
reflect on the book that changed his
life
i wrote my first book more than three
decades ago it was part memoir and part
reportage
liar's poker it was called
the book hit some kind of nerve in our
culture
michael lewis led us in on the way wall
street really works with liar's poker i
mean i didn't even really know the
culture had nerves
i'd never done this before i had no idea
what to expect
the book shot right to the top of every
bestseller list and stayed on them for a
year
and right away i noticed something odd
i thought i'd written a book that put
wall street in its place
[Applause]
the place has become in the last 10
years a fantastic casino
i thought that like any 20 year old who
was contemplating a career on wall
street might read my book and decide to
go do something more deeply enriching
but that's not what happened
[Music]
in the first few months i had maybe a
thousand letters from people mainly
young men saying i love your book dude
i'm now totally stoked to go work on
wall street you got any more tips on how
i can get in what i thought of as a
cautionary tale became an instruction
manual that's when i learned that
writers simply write books
readers decide what the words mean at
the time i thought that liar's poker
marked the end of a special period of
financial madness there is something
rotten in the state of wall street
there were 184 bank failures major
charges alleging the widespread illegal
use of insider information his firm
solomon brothers stands accused of
illegal trading in government bonds
[Music]
i was a 25 year old art history major
who knew very little about money and yet
grown-ups were paying me hundreds of
thousands of dollars a year to move huge
piles of money around i thought i was
simply documenting the end of an era of
absolute madness on wall street but it
turns out this era was just the
beginning of something bigger
of wall street grabbing an ever larger
share of the u.s economy
of the people on wall street living by
one set of rules and most everyone else
living by another
i moved on after i wrote the book i mean
i never even read it again
but i've written a couple of more books
about wall street and i know that the
world described in liar's poker has
changed wall street used to be full of
telephones with cords on them and
shouting and big hairy men it was crude
and rude and socially unacceptable wall
street's now gone quiet its most
important sound is the hum of a stack of
computer servers
the people take a lot more care and not
to draw attention to themselves
i think that's the main reason that
people still read my book why say
interns on wall street are assigned it
as homework because i'd gotten the last
glimpse of the great beast before it
ducked back inside its cave and i
accidentally wrote something that
endured just recently i found out that
the audiobook writes to liars poker had
reverted back to me so i decided to
reopen liar's poker and record it again
the whole thing ready
[Music]
it was a truly weird experience almost
like meeting a different me
it was actually difficult to read the
book again
but it reminded me of the value of not
always just moving forward of taking the
time to stop and go back
i've thrown everything about liars poker
into a couple of bankers boxes and left
them sealed up in a storage unit for
decades
after we recorded the audiobook i pulled
those boxes out and looked inside
there was a whole other me in there
a guy who for a long time couldn't even
see a decent book title staring him
right in the face
but also a guy who knew he had a good
story in front of him and i had to
admire his strange decision to leave a
huge pile of money behind to write a
book that he thought could change the
world
even if it didn't change the world in
the ways he expected
the liars poker audiobook and companion
podcast other people's money are out now
yeah look at michael lewis back in the
day i like what he said he thought it
would be a cautionary tale instead of
his instruction manual that's right
readers decide what it means we'll be
right back